I want your help
oh yeah someone needs to run to the
store for smokes this will go on all
night but it might not be your okay it
might not be okay
Congress will spook shareholders I'm on
a knife's edge ten bad minutes on camera
and DC that could be it
the end the end come on
I need you to chase down the sovereign
wealth money okay right I mean that's
it's a cool idea
it's kind of a stretch you know that
Central Asian money that's no-strings
dry powder time out from the
responsibilities of being a public
company
that's a lifeline can you do it
can I do it um but Dad um I want to say
yes but I'll be honest if it's like
really important I mean I can say I can
do it like you know a fireman in a movie
but honestly I you act the fuck-knuckle
but you know people like you it's a
really big deal to set up anyone
could do a deal he's getting the right
number from the red suit getting your
dick in there is easy getting them into
bed that's hard for some you can do it
then uh yeah sure dad I got it
keep me close okay take Laird and call
for the details
great I'm on it Oh also just to check
Marshall Mystere Azure is that okay are
you okay do you have something that you
can speak to about it
you want me to speak to a shrink
yeah you may want to screw your Mayer
but I am okay in that department thank
you great well it's just nice that we
can talk about these things I'm gonna go
you